mais l'album les gens minérale il
s'appelle le musique et sa femme
voilà vous êtes une sorte de moujik de
la musique certaine façon c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal comme formule magique de
la musique ensanglantent c'est un paysan
russe si tu as ça vous gêne de faire la
promo à la télé non j'aime beaucoup ça
parce que j'ai lu des propos de vous pas
désobligeant pour moi mais très très
très désobligeant pour mais bon mes
confrères vous êtes sûr de pas faire
leurs émissions si vous n'avez pas envie
de faire de promo à la télé si vous
n'avez pas en faire parce que j'avais le
choix c'était vous fogiel
ouais je vous ai choisis vous ces
chantiers les saloperies sur fogiel
j'aurais pu dire sur vous aussi soyez
chez fuji a tiré au sort voilà c'est
avec votre copain là il n'y est pas allé
de main morte avec fogiel a way ils
viendront pas stéphane avec vous ils
abhorrent match que j'ai vu c'est votre
copal mais montre pas stéphane sur vous
il va d'abord dire ce que votre copain
stéphane soumier on va voir votre copain
l'a donc il dit en parlant de marc
olivier fogiel il se trémousse tellement
on dirait qu'il a collé un gode sur sa
chaise sénile
c'est nul ça sympa non là vous serez
plus obligé d'y aller chez fogiel vous
savez ça maintenant qu'ici m'inviter
choix juillet les avants mais il faut
pas content il faut que je vous ai c'est
signer avec les blagues de mon copain
était d'accord mais vous épargner pas le
métier non plus en parlant du patron
d'universal pascal [ __ ] à succès dédié
remarquer ses ventes si vous êtes le
seul en fait ce qui est génial c'est
celui dit des trucs pour ça que c'est
drôle quoi bah ouais ça que tu lances
dans le pascal [ __ ] le patron
d'universal vous avez dit qu'elle ou de
charcutier la normale heures gala
devrait dé couper des têtes de hausser
sa géniale
bon en revanche dans les détails des
vaches qui milite aussi des trucs très
vrai vous avez dit c'est vrai que la
chanson française ressemble de plus en
plus à la variété internationale de
moins en moins d'auteur compositeur
interprète est de plus en plus
d'interprètes dans les maisons de
disques font absolument ce qu'elle veut
c'est vrai c'est bientôt vous trouvez ça
pertinents ouais je trouve sa pertinence
d'autant plus que vous d'autant plus que
vous ajoutez des juillet prenez une
photo tient dans ville je trouve cela
pertinent d'autant plus vous a ajouté
que ce sont tous des chanteurs de balle
je trouve ça assez de la revue art dit
c'est que finalement ce qui est typique
de cette nouvelle race de chanteur ce
sont les chanteurs québécois parce
qu'ils ont trop fort est parce que je
pense que la langue française une langue
de c'est une langue de la de l'intimité
et de la passion et du plaisir
c'est donc plutôt une langue chuchoter
c'est vrai que oui c'est vrai que les
gens qui parlent fort du mal à penser
finement et je crois par les chanteurs
c'est un peu pareil si tu veux parler un
tout petit peu plus fort parce qu'on
défend pas
le public qui s'appelle baby karni birds
sur le loft
j'ai pas aimé love story vo totalement
ne serait pas mise assez comment la
presse il comment les gens se sont
engouffrés là dedans elle devenue une
sorte de sport national de commenter
cette chose est assez médiocre c'était
un peu humiliant pour tout le monde je
serai tout le monde s'engage et là
dedans il ya un type très connue au
monde s'appelle daniel schneidermann qui
donne des leçons de morale à tout le
monde toutes les semaines il a écrit le
spectacle en allant du loft
le spectacle de télévision le plus neuf
le plus créatif et le plus intéressant
programmer ces dernières années sur les
écrans français
face à ces derniers dans le monde en
conneries saint séverin ouais ouais t'as
remarqué
oui j'ai remarqué c'est le même boli
m'bolhi chassons selon cette porte pour
nom une légère à lui avait réservé
celui-là alors eh ben oui alors oui vous
avez d'autres fiches d'un paquet fille
j'en ai plein pour le oui non en fait je
me dire pourquoi j'ai pris pichotte que
vous êtes un titre quand même assez
paradoxale d'un côté vous êtes énervé
par ces chanteurs qu'on lance comme des
savonnettes la visite moi je bosse
pendant des heures avec mon piano ma
guitare et tout moi je suis un vrai quoi
je travaille je me donne du mal et en
fait quand on voit comment vous avez
enregistré ce disque que vous
promotionner aujourd'hui le moujik et sa
femme vous dites que vous l'avez
enregistré en douze heures
ouais comme dilemme 2 heures par jour on
a vu des mecs qui met de trois ans pour
faire un album mais brands l'un d'eux
d'europe en faire un homme comme style
génisson par antoine laurent voulzy la
mise en avant pour faire son album c'est
du marketing au reste du temps on
faisait du foot à la piscine le nom
jeune âge et des pétards non je mets les
musiciens et la mémoire c'est fini ça
pas vous êtes bonnes critiques c'est
essentiel d'être content là comme
d'habitude libération les inrocks
comment sa libération et the rock mais
malheureux il ya des centaines de médias
ayant un impact de ce que c'est vous qui
vous ouvre ses mouillettes voulez vous
disais que c'est demain et pas du tout
ranger lui elle aussi à vous lisez elle
est en dépôt des photos non je lis un
jeu j'ai vu qu' il y avait toutes les
femmes du super derrière des cuivres
toutes les femmes de l disent du bien de
vous vous êtes très très très aimé des
femmes
katherine pancol pascale clark christine
angot car denis verdini ma copine kg
mais les femmes elles vous le rendent
bien
quel gardien bien parce que vous l'aimez
fait sophie d'envoi ouais en même temps
je l'aï beaucoup aussi les chevaux comme
la fumée mais j'aime beaucoup
non c'est vrai vous dit quand je tombe
amoureux c'est une opportunité pour
changer chaque film chamboule je prends
ces gestes je change de toilettes si
elle se lève plus tard je me cale sur
son rythme si elle s'habille en grenat
je vais m'acheter des trucs grenat ses
profits c'est ça l'amour c'est l'amour
c'est en fait une forme de labour est
pas en forme ce qui moi je vais très
bien ça va comme d'habitude elles sont
pas terribles ces questions c'est pas
des questionnements on verra mieux fait
d'aller chez fogiel précieux
c'est un prochain album c'est quand dans
deux jours vous êtes adulé par la
critique c'est vrai j'ai pas rendre
public le 20 mai les ventes ne suivent
pas comment ça se fait je m'en sens
mieux à chaque fois ça me va très bien
ça suffit les clauses de trois albums en
même temps que tu paies 300000 commence
à ce que vous soyez pas un chanteur
populaire ce qui est cher et rare ouais
nous passer en radio malanda sont elles
sont obligées de passer des chansons
françaises de la radio non c'est une ba
et ba j'ai un petit budget pour faire ce
disque là non c'est de la blague s'agit
d'une énorme
normal parce que votre maison de disques
il paraît qu'ils donneront deux fois
moins s'ils marchent pas de disque vas-y
amuse-toi vais faire une demi l'audience
c'est lorsqu'on est un peu le parent
pauvre dans votre maison de disques
n'ont pas du tout non
je suis le chouchou mais parions que
vous fait la promo ouais vous êtes dans
un très bel hôtel pour recevoir les
journalistes et après vous allez dormir
dans un hôtel moins bien c'est vrai bah
oui c'est normal
pourquoi tu fais pas l'un vers ce
combat-là la verdir lui donne pas un bel
hôtel n'était jour ça que je comprends
pas non mais je pense qu à peine de
dépenser des fortunes dans les chambres
d'hôtel un lycéen lee c'est vrai que
voulez vous installer dans le sud par
exemple question idiote comme ça mais
qui peut vous donne l'occasion de vous
exprimer oui oui
alors oui je suis pas encore truction je
pensais je veux quitter l'auvergne
voilà une question non je sais pas
encore en ambiance pas